HIS HOME.
>>> AND THE TRIBUTES FOR ELVIS'S
ONLY CHILD.
>>> I'M KATE BOLDUAN.
WE START IN THE SOUTH AS WE'RE
TRACKING WHAT IS LEFT BEHIND
REALLY FROM A DEADLY TORNADO
OUTBREAK.
DOZENS HAVE BEEN REPORTED IN
ALABAMA, GEORGIA AND KENTUCKY.
SEVEN PEOPLE WERE KILLED, SIX OF
THEM IN A SINGLE ALABAMA COUNTY.
ONE OF THE HARDEST HIT AREAS WAS
A CITY OF SELMA, WHERE A TORNADO
CAUSED WIDESPREAD DAMAGE,
STRUCTURES JUST TORN APART AND
LIVES SHATTERED.
THIS MORNING AUTHORITIES ARE
GETTING A CLEARER PICTURE OF THE
EXTEND OF THE DAMAGE AND WHAT
THEY NEED TO PICK UP AND CLEAN
UP AND STILL SEARCHING FOR MORE
SURVIVORS.
LET'S GO TO SELMA, ALABAMA.
RYAN YOUNG IS STANDING BY FOR
US.
RYAN, LOOK AT THAT.
>> Reporter: IT IS JUST
DEVASTATING BEHIND US.
AND I COULD TELL YOU, IN THE
CLOSE COUNTY, THEY HAVE FOUND
MORE BODIES BUT HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO UPDATE US.
THEY'RE DOING SURVEYS ACROSS THE
STATE.
BUT WE WANT TO SHOW YOU HOW
POWERFUL THIS STORM WAS.
I'M SIX FEET TALL.
LOOK AT THIS METAL WRAPS ALL
OVER THIS TREE LIKE IT IS AN
ORNAMENT.
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE SEEING, SIGNS
OF DESTRUCTION ALL OVER THIS
CITY.
WE ARE ON BROAD STREET, WHICH IS
THE MAIN STREET HERE IN DOWNTOWN
SELMA.
AND AS YOU LOOK THIS DIRECTION,
YOU COULD JUST SEE HOW THE STORM
PLOWED THROUGH THIS AREA.
WE'RE GOING TO WALK THIS WAY TO
SHOW THAT YOU BUILDING IN THE
BACKGROUND.
AS WE WERE LOOKING AROUND AND
EVEN DOING OUR OWN ASSESSMENT,
THERE ARE HOUSES THAT THEY STILL
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO REACH
BECAUSE THERE ARE TREES DOWN
THROUGHOUT THE AREA.
POWER COMPANIES HAVE BEEN TRYING
TO RESTORE SOME OF THE POWER AND
PHONE SERVICE IS VERY SPOTTY
THROUGHOUT THIS AREA.
PEOPLE DID NOT KNOW THIS STORM
WOULD BE THAT POWERFUL AND HAD
TO RUN FOR A CLOSET BECAUSE THEY
WERE TERRIFIED BY WHAT THEY WERE
HEARING.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WE HAD TO RUN FOR COVER.
WE HAD TO GO RUN AND JUMP IN THE
CLOSET.
>> OH, MY GOD.
OH, MY GOD.
OH, MY GOD, LOOK.
THAT IS THE BUILDING BESIDE US.
OH, MY GOD.
>> AND KATE, JUST TO TELL YOU
HOW DANGEROUS SOME OF THE AREA
IS, LOOK, THERE ARE PIECES OF
WOOD ALL THROUGHOUT THIS AREA
JUST LIKE THIS ONE.
BUT YOU COULD TELL THAT THE
NAILS ARE STILL STICKING OUT.
THIS WAS A PROJECTILE THAT WAS
GOING THROUGH PEOPLE'S WINDOWS
AND AS YOU LOOK ACROSS THE WAY
HERE, YOU COULD JUST SEE THE
DAMAGE THAT HAS BEEN LEFT
BEHIND, CARS HAVE BEEN
DESTROYED, HOUSES HAVE BEEN TORN
TO PIECES AND WE STILL DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE TOTAL ASSESSMENT
IS JUST YET.
A HELICOPTER WAS JUST FLYING
OVER FROM THE STATE AS THEY WERE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE TO
SEND THE EMERGENCY CREWS.
THEY WILL BE DOING THIS FOR
QUITE SOMETIME.
THE CLEAN-UP WILL BE MASSIVE AND
IS THIS STRETCHED ALL THE WAY TO
GEORGIA.
SO AS YOU UNDERSTAND, AS FIRST
LIGHT COMES UP, PEOPLE ARE STILL
SHAKING THEIR HEADS WONDERING
HOW THIS STORM WAS SO POWERFUL
AND HOW IT HIT SO QUICK LEAVING
A LOT OF PEOPLE CAUGHT OFF GUARD
AND NOW TODAY THEY'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHO IS LEFT AND HOW
MANY MORE BODIES WILL THEY FIND
TODAY.
>> AND, RYAN, WHERE YOU STARTED
AND WHAT YOU SHOWED REALLY IS A
TERRIFYING DEPICTION OF JUST HOW
POWERFUL THIS STORM MUST HAVE
BEEN.
AND HOW POWERFUL THE TORNADO
WAS.
TO SEE THE METAL WRAPPED AROUND
THAT HUGE TREE LIKE TINFOIL OR
TISSUE PAPER, WE'VE SEEN
DESTRUCTION FROM TORNADOS
UNFORTUNATELY MANY TIMES IN THE
PAST.
THAT IS QUITE AN IMAGE TO BE
SEEING AND TO BE WAKING UP TO
TODAY.
>> AND THIS IS -- ABSOLUTELY.
AND THIS IS BEEN A VERY ACTIVE
YEAR ALREADY.
THIS AREA IS USED TO HAVING
TORNADOS.
BUT TO HAVE THIS ONE COME ON TOP
OF EVERYONE SO QUICKLY AND THEN
TO HAVE EVERYONE SORT OF TRYING
TO SCRAMBLE TO GET COVER.
IT HAD TO BE TERRIFIED
YESTERDAY.
>> THANK YOU FOR BEING THERE.
RYAN WILL CONTINUE TO DO GREAT
REPORTING ON THE GROUND FOR US.
>>> RYAN MENTIONS GEORGIA.
IN GEORGIA, ONE DEATH HAS SO FAR
BEEN CONFIRMED.
A 5-YEAR-OLD WAS KILLED AFTER A
TREE FELL ON TOP OF A CAR.
DARE VAN DAMME IS IN GRIFFIN,
GEORGIA, WITH A LOOK AT THE
DAMAGE THERE.
DEREK, WHAT ARE YOU SEEING?
>> Reporter: TRAGICALLY, THE ONE
FATALITY IN STATE OF GEORGIA WAS
IN AN ADJACENT COUNTY TO WHERE I
AM NOW, IN SPAULDING COUNTY.
IT WAS LIKELY PART OF THE SAME
TORNADO THAT CYCLED UP AND DOWN
CAUSING THE DESTRUCTION YOU SEE
BEHIND ME.
WHAT YOU'RE ACTUALLY LOOKING AT
IS THE TOP ROOF OF A LARGE
SHOPPING CENTER.
YOU COULD SEE A HOBBY LOBBY IN
MY BACK HERE, THERE WAS A GAS
LEAK THAT HAS SINCE BEEN
CONTAINED.
BUT WHEN WE ARRIVED ON THE SCENE
LAST NIGHT, YOU COULD SMELL THE
GAS, AND YOU COULD HEAR THE GAS
ESCAPING AS WELL.
AS RYAN SAID, IT IS BEEN SUCH AN
ACTIVE YEAR FOR TORNADOS.
JUST WITH THIS LATER ROUND,
THERE WERE 35 TORNADOS.
BUT TO DATE WE'VE HAD NEARLY 100
TORNADOS ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN
11 DIFFERENT STATES OCCURRING IN
PLACES LIKE CALIFORNIA AND
ILLINOIS.
IN GEORGIA WE'VE HAD THREE DAYS
OF TORNADOS SO FAR THIS YEAR.
THAT IS NEARLY A QUARTER OF THE
DAYS OF 2023.
SO WE'RE FOUR TIMES THE AVERAGE
NUMBER OF TORNADOS SO FAR IN
2023 TO DATE.
THAT IS JUST INCREDIBLE.
HERE IN SPAULDING COUNTY, KATE,
WE HEARD ABOUT FOUR MIDDLE
SCHOOLS THAT HAD TO SHELTER IN
PLACE DURING THE HEIGHT OF THE
TORNADO AS IT MOVED THROUGH.
THE DAMAGE WAS SO BAD LEADING UP
TO THE SCHOOLS THAT THEY
ACTUALLY HAD TO KEEP THE
CHILDREN IN THE SCHOOL UP UNTIL
ABOUT MIDNIGHT LAST NIGHT WHEN
AUTHORITIES DEEMED THAT IT WAS
SAFE FOR THEM TO TAKE THE BUSES
HOME TO RETURN THEM TO THEIR
RESIDENCE.
SO WITH THE FATALITY IN BUTTS
COUNTY TO MY EAST, A CHILD
LOSING THEIR LIFE, YET ANOTHER
STORY TO REPORT FROM IN THE
SOUTH OF ABOVE AVERAGE TORNADO
SEASON, VERY, VERY DIFFICULT
YEAR ALREADY.
KATE.
>> SURE THING.
DEREK, THANK YOU FOR THAT.
>>> LET ME BRING IN
METEOROLOGIST CHAD MYERS ON
THIS.
AND YOU'VE BEEN LOOKING AT THE
LIVE SHOTS FROM DEREK AND RYAN
ALONG WITH ME AND JUST THE
DAMAGE THAT WE'VE SEEN.
DOZENS OF TORNADOS IN THE SOUTH.
WE'RE SHOWING A LIVE PICTURE IN
SELMA, AS WELL.
HOW STRONG WERE THESE TORNADOS
TO DO THIS.
>> THE ONE THAT MOVED OVER SELMA
SKIPPED A BIT AND THEN SET BACK
DOWN AS A VERY, VERY VIOLENT
TORNADO IN THE ATAUGA COUNTY
AREA.
AND THE WEATHER SERVICE FROM
BIRMINGHAM PICKED UP PIECES OF
DEBRIS.
THE RADAR COULD DISTINGUISH
BETWEEN SHINGLES AND RAIN DROPS
AND CAN'T TELL YOU IF IT IS A
STICK OR A TWIG OR A LEAF BUT IT
IS NOT A RAIN DROP.
AND SOME OF THAT DEBRIS WAS
200 -- JUST 20,000 FEET TALL.
20,000 FEET IN THE AIR.
THAT IS HOW MUCH IT WAS SUCKING
ACROSS PARTS OF THIS AREA.
JUST TAKING THIS TORNADO, TAKING
THIS DAMAGE AND JUST THROWING IT
OUTSIDE ON THE TOP OF THIS
TORNADO.
THIS IS JUST WHERE WE'RE GOING
TO BE DEVASTATING.
THE WEATHER SERVICE OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW TRYING TO LOOK AT WHAT
IT WAS.
WAS IT AN EF 3 OR SOMETHING
STRONGER.
THEY'RE NOT RARE.
BUT THE NUMBER SO FAR THIS YEAR
CERTAINLY WOULD BE RARE.
THERE THEY ARE.
AND BECAUSE WE HAVE 35 AND I SEE
SO MANY DOTS SO CLOSE TO EACH
OTHER, I THINK MAYBE THAT IS THE
SAME TORNADO ON THE GROUND FOR
QUITE SOMETIME.
THERE IS WHERE THE RAIN IS NOW.
IT IS NOT SEVERE ACROSS PARTS OF
FLORIDA.
JUST A COOLER AIR MASS.
AND IN BUFFALO IT IS SNOW, AND
AS ALSO SOME SNOW TRYING TO GET
TO NASHVILLE.
IT COULD MAKE ITS WAY INTO NORTH
GEORGIA AS WE WORK INTO TONIGHT.
OUT TO WEST, YES, THIS IS WHERE
IT IS GOING TO RAIN AND SNOW
AGAIN.
BUT ONLY FOR JUST MAYBE THREE
MORE DAYS, MAYBE FOUR.
THERE IS GOING TO BE RAIN AND
SNOW IN THE MOUNTAINS.
BUT BY THE TIME WE WORK INTO
NEXT THURSDAY, THE FORECAST IS
FOR BELOW NORMAL PRECIP.
AND THE FORECAST FOR THAT IS
ABOUT AS GOOD AS YOU COULD GET
FOR THE PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
>> NO KIDDING.
THANKS, CHAD.
APPRECIATE YOU WATCHING ALL OF
THIS FOR US.
>>> AND LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT
THE ALABAMA AND THE DESTRUCTION
THERE.
RICKY ADAMS IS JOINING US, THE
FIELD OF OPERATIONS FOR
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO SPEAK WITH ME.
WE'RE SEEING SOME OF THE
PICTURES COMING OUT OF ALABAMA
ARE JUST --
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> -- ARE JUST HEARTBREAKING.
WE'RE LOOKING AT A LIVE LOOK IN
SELMA, THIS MORNING.
WHAT IS YOUR TOP PRIORITY TODAY?
>> YEAH, YOUR RIGHT.
>> IT WAS A VERY SIGNIFICANT
WEATHER DAY YESTERDAY.
AND IT CONTINUES TO BE LIFE
SAVING AND IN ANY OF THOSE AREAS
WHERE SEARCH AND RESCUE IS BEING
CONDUCTED AND AFTER THAT WILL BE
AN ASSESSMENT OR ONGOING
ASSESSMENT OF THE DAMAGES AND
NEEDS OF THE CITIZENS SO WE
COULD HELP THE COUNTY PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE RESOURCES THAT
THEY NEED.
>> LATEST THAT WE'VE HEARD IS
THAT AT LEAST SIX PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN KILLED IN YOUR STATE.
THE CORONER IN AUTAUGA SAID
THEY'RE FINDING MORE BODIES THIS
MORNING.
WHERE DOES THE DEATH TOLL STAND
RIGHT NOW.
>> IT WAS A DEATH TOLL INCREASED
TO SEVEN.
AND SEARCH AND RESCUE EFFORTS
CONTINUE.
I SPOKE TO ERNIE BAGUETTE, WHO
IS THE EMA DIRECTOR THIS MORNING
AND THE REASON THAT THE SEARCH
AND RESCUE IS CONTINUING BECAUSE
OF WHERE THE FATALITIES
OCCURRED, THERE WAS A
COMBINATION OF OCCUPIED AND
UNOCCUPIED DWELLINGS OR HOMES
THERE AND THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THEY GO THROUGH ALL OF THE
DEBRIS AND ACCOUNT FOR ANY OF
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT MAY HAVE
LIVED THERE.
IT IS SAY HORRIBLE MESS.
>> A HORRIBLE MESS.
WE'VE BEEN TOLD THAT THE
TORNADOS THAT HIT SELMA WAS
LIKELY ON THE GROUND FOR 50
MILES.
I MEAN, THE NATIONAL WEATHER
SERVICE DESCRIBED IT AS BEING ON
THE GROUND FOR A LONG TIME.
CHAD MEYER, OUR METEOROLOGIST
DESCRIBING JUST HOW HIGH IN THE
AIR SOME OF THIS DEBRIS WAS
SUCKED UP.
JUST SHOWING THE FORCE OF THIS
TORNADO.
HOW DO YOU DESCRIBE WHAT -- WHAT
IS HAPPENED THERE?
>> WELL, AS YOU SAID EARLIER,
ALABAMA IS NO STRANGER TO
TORNADOS.
IT WAS A VERY INTENSE STORM AND
MAYBE EVEN BEEN ON THE GROUND
MORE THAN 50 MILES.
WE'LL WAIT FOR THE NATIONAL
WEATHER SERVICE TO ASSESS THAT.
WE ESTIMATE THAT AT LEAST 30